die scheidende Verteidigungsministerin
kurz vor ihrer letzten Amtshandlung im
Berliner bentlerblock wartet Christine
Lambrecht auf ihre Nachfolger gemeinsam
geht's dann zum Programmpunkt
Abschreiten der Ehrenformation dabei
braucht es noch ein bisschen
Hilfestellung für den neuen vor Boris
Pistorius schnurstracks ins neue
amtmarschiert
der Bundeswehr kommt in der Zeitenwende
eine Schlüsselrolle zu
meine Aufgabe wird es sein und daran
setzt sich alle meine Kraft dass die
Bundeswehr diesen Auftrag erfüllen kann
im Interesse Deutschlands im Interesse
der NATO und dem Interesse der Menschen
eine Aufgabe die sicherlich keine
leichte wird so viel steht fest
Durchhaltevermögen hat der
Bundespräsident im neuen
Verteidigungsminister mit auf den Weg
gegeben als er ihm heute früh die
Ernennungsurkunde ausgehändigt hat in
diesem Umfeld neuer Bedrohungen
geopolitische Veränderungen kommt es
jetzt entscheidend darauf an die
Bundeswehr abschreckungsfähig und
verteidigungsbereit zu machen sie muss
konsequent auf ihren kernauftrag der
Landes und Bündnis Verteidigung
ausgerichtet werden neben dieser
Neuausrichtung der Bundeswehr den
Neuanschaffungen von Material und
Ausrüstung geht es auch immer wieder um
die militärische Unterstützung der
Ukraine doch immer lauter werdenden
Forderungen nach deutschen Kampfpanzern
für Kiew den will und will sich der
Kanzler nicht beugen in einem Telefonat
mit US-Präsident beiden soll Scholz
gesagt haben wenn ihr K Panzer liefert
dann liefern wir auch aber nur dann
die Amerikaner sie liefern allerdings
keine Kampfpanzer erstmal gibt es
Schützenpanzer vom Typ Striker der
Kampfpanzer Abrams bleibt bislang ebenso
tabu wie Deutschlands Leopard
die Kampfpanzer waren sicherlich auch
Thema beim ersten Arbeitstreffen von
Boris Pistorius mit seinem
amerikanischen Amtskollegen Austin
öffentlich gesagt wird das nicht
Pistorius verweist lieber auf das bisher
gelieferte Gerät
deutsche Systeme bewähren sich in der
Ukraine
panzerwitzen Gepard oder hochmodernes
Flugabwehrsystem ihres tssl
und gemeinsam das kann ich sagen werden
wir auch in Zukunft mit unseren Partnern
gemeinsam die Ukraine in ihrem Kampf für
die Freiheit und die territarreale
Unabhängigkeit und Souveränität
unterstützen dem stimmt Leute aus den
ausdrücklich zu Lob Deutschlands Ukraine
Unterstützung
wir werden morgen den Ramstein gemeinsam
mit der Ukraine Kontaktgruppe beraten
wie und was wir noch an Unterstützung
leisten können hier und heute bereiten
wir das bilateral vor
erster Arbeitstag ordentlich viel
Programm daran wird sich der neue
Verteidigungsminister gewöhnen müssen
ja und zentral bleibt noch die Frage
nach Panzerlieferungen westlicher Bauart
an die Ukraine Scholz sagt ja wenn die
USA auch ihre Pumps Kampfpanzer liefern
die Abrams so die aktuelle Lesart haben
wir eben gerade noch mal gehört fragen
wir nach bei unserem USA Korrespondenten
elmar-wissen schönen guten Tag nach
Washington ist da bei dem heutigen
Treffen noch eine Antwort dahingehend zu
erwarten
es wird wahrscheinlich bei dem Nein zu
den Abrams Panzern bleiben und hier in
Washington schütten schütteln
Militärexperten eigentlich den Kopf über
den deutschen Bundeskanzler sie sagen
dass diese Bedingungen Leopard 2 nur
dann wenn Amerika Abrams liefert im
Grunde genommen von Unwissenheit in
Deutschland zeugt oder nur eine
Ausflucht ist und das hat eben einen
Grund die Leopard zwei Panzer die
britischen Challenger zwei Panzer auch
die Bradley wie häkels die die
Amerikaner liefern werden sie alle
laufen auf diese Treibstoff dafür ist
die Versorgungskette in der Ukraine
gewährleistet der Evans Panzer
allerdings braucht ein Gemisch aus
Kerosin also Flugzeug Treibstoff und
normalem Benzin und diese Mischung ist
logistisch eigentlich in der Ukraine
nicht herzustellen das müsste erst
mühsam aufgebaut werden insofern macht
die Lieferung von airbrems Panzern
eigentlich keinen Sinn aber die
Amerikaner wollen das alles geliefert
wird damit die Ukraine eine
Frühjahrsoffensive führen kann und dazu
gehören neben Striker und Bradleys auch
die Challenger 2 und eben auch der
Leopard 2 für den die nachschubkette in
der Ukraine gewährleistet werden kann
also andere Rüstungen hast du schon
angesprochen Elmar aus den USA wird also
grundsätzlich anderes kommen auch Waffen
mit denen eine Rückeroberung der Krim
möglicherweise denkbar wäre ändert das
dann etwas an der
Neuausrichtung ist das eine
Neuausrichtung der US-Strategie
ja das ist es wohl es gab in den letzten
Wochen hier im Pentagon aber auch im
Weißen Haus Beratungen und angesichts
der massiven Raketenangriffe auf
ukrainische Städte durch eben die
russischen Streitkräfte diesmal zu dem
Schluss gekommen man muss eine wirksame
Frühjahrsoffensive führen und das kann
nur dann gelingen wenn man gleichzeitig
die große Schutzzone die die Russen
benutzen für den Nachschub aber eben
auch für ihre Angriffe und das ist die
Krim wenn die Kontrolle über diese
Schutzzone in ein Risiko wirkte oder in
Frage gestellt werden kann und das kann
eben nur gelingen wenn man den Landweg
zur zur Krim abschneide das geht hier
nicht um eine Rückeroberung sondern es
geht um ein Signal an Moskau klar zu
machen dass die Kontrolle über die Grimm
gefährdet ist und damit eine bessere
Ausgangsposition dann für mögliche
Verhandlungen auch in der Zukunft zu
erzielen Einschätzung von unserem USA
Korrespondenten Elma Wissen vielen Dank
ja und einschätzen lassen wollen wir uns
das ganze auch noch vom österreichischen
Militärexperten Gustav geresselt schönen
guten Tag das große Thema sind ja gerade
die geforderten Leopard 2 Panzer haben
wir eben auch noch mal drüber gesprochen
und aktuell gibt es diese Bedingung des
Kanzlers Deutschland liefere nur wenn
die USA den Abrams Kampfpanzer auch
liefern schauen wir mal drauf welchen
Unterschied würde denn der Leopard 2
überhaupt machen
der Hauptunterschied des Leopard 2 ist
in der Ukraine wäre die einfache
logistische Versorgung die
danach schon an panzermunition für 125
mm also das sowjetische Kaliber wird
zunehmend schwierig der Verbraucher ist
enorm hoch in der Ukraine der besten
stellt diese Munition nur eingeschränkt
hier einige munitionsfirmen in Polen
Tschechische Republik und Bulgarien und
es ist ein genauso im Falle der
Artillerie im vorher auch schon war
einfach einfacher westliche Munition zu
liefern damit die Ukraine aber westliche
Munition verschießen kann brauchst du
auch einen Panzer aus dem das rausgeht
und das wäre natürlich einfach oder am
einfachsten zu bewerkstelligen wenn es
der Leopard 2 wäre
die westlichen Verbündeten sehen in der
Lieferung von Leopard 2 Kampfpanzern
aber offenbar auch eine neue Dimension
warum tut sich die Bundeswehr dann damit
ihrer Meinung nach so schwer wenn es im
Grunde um logistische Sachen geht
naja das ist eher eine deutsche
Vorstellung dass der Leopard 2 dann eine
komplette Veränderung des Krieges vor
sich bringt der Leopard 2 ist wichtig um
eine Durchhaltefähigkeit eine
Nachhaltigkeit der ukrainischen
mechanisierten Reserven und insbesondere
der Panzerwaffe zu gewährleisten wir
müssen uns aber im Klaren sein dass
Lieferungen dann mit Instandsetzung von
von Materialien mit sammeln
verschiedenster Panzer aus
unterschiedlichen Staaten dass das auch
eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit hat und seine
Zeit braucht bis diese Lieferungen dann
auch wirklich in Ukraine wirksam werden
also in dem Sinne ist das jetzt
ich glaube da wird in Deutschland zu
viel zu viel Spekulationen damit
verbunden und und das schadet natürlich
auch auch dem Diskurs mit unseren
Nachbarstaaten weil die die deutsche
leopardsweit ist Diskussion so absurd
anders ist als die im Rest der Welt dann
lassen Sie uns nochmal drauf schauen sie
haben gerade gesagt dass es gar nicht so
schnell gehen wird den Leopard 2 Panzer
dorthin zu liefern und auch Ersatzteile
etc was heißt denn nicht so schnell ab
wann gäbe es denn dann da die
Möglichkeit den wirklich einzusetzen
bei all diesen jetzt zugesagten Geräten
der läuft zum Teil schon die Ausbildung
da wird ein bisschen ein Vorbereitung
nötig sein und die werden dann etwa im
Frühling in der Ukraine einfließen das
kommt
das Problem dass wir beim Leopard haben
und warum all diese Zahlen die genannt
werden ein bisschen Rauch ist weil wir
eben eine eine sehr verweigernde
Erhaltung das Kanzlers haben wo immer
neue Ausreden erfunden werden warum das
nicht geschehen hat das Problem ist es
ist erstens ich muss wissen welche
Fahrzeugen welche Fahrzeuge sich konkret
aus welchem Depot handelt um den den
Material entstand setzungsbedarf
wirklich abschätzen zu können und
zweitens muss ich auch wissen wie es mit
der Nachbarschaft dann von Ersatzgeräten
ausschaut alles kann ich erst angehen
wenn ich ein okay aus dem Kanzleramt
habe dass dieser panzertyp überhaupt in
Ukraine kann dann kann ich erst anfangen
vernünftig zu und realistisch zu planen
wie viele Fahrzeuge zu welchem Zeitpunkt
aus welchem Land wo abgehen und bzw dann
auch wonach bestellt werden all das
haben wir noch nicht möchten sonst noch
ganz kurz auf die Gesamtlage schauen
Moskau hat schon erklärt die Zahl der
russischen Soldaten auf 1,5 Millionen
aufstocken zu wollen beide Russland und
die Ukraine planen vermutlich eine
Frühjahrsoffensive also wo stehen wir in
diesem Krieg derzeit
wir stehen im Krieg derzeit das Russland
langsam die Initiative wieder
zurückgewinnt es hat ja im Herbst mobil
gemacht und diese mobilgemachten
Einheiten die jetzt langsam zu
wirklichen Verbänden trainiert wurden
die Fließen jetzt langsam in die Ukraine
ein wir es ist damit zu rechnen dass
sich die russischen Angriffe jetzt in
den in den nächsten Monaten
intensivieren die Ukraine muss durch
diese schwierige Zeit durch verteidigen
und kann genauso wie das letztes Jahr
war dem Moment wo die russischen Kräfte
verbraucht sind über den sind dann dazu
ansetzen Gegenangriffe zu fahren und
wieder Territorium zu befreien das ist
im Grunde eine Wiederholung des letzten
Jahres sagt der österreichische
Militärexperte Gustav gressel vielen
Dank für Ihre Zeit heute